[Musica]
[Applauso]
c'era una volta una pecora si chiamava
dolly e quando nacque nella campagna
scozzese nell'ormai lontano 1996 non si
sarebbe mai attesa tanta celebrità
ad annunciare la nascita un fax chef
bimbo fiera white face and free lance
wow niente di più normale per il primo
mammifero clonato con successo da
cellule adulte fotocopia esatta di un
altro esemplare dolly aveva il
patrimonio genetico identico a quello
della sua mamma ed era venuta al mondo
aveva iniziato la sua vita in una
provetta
tutto questo grazie alla biotecnologia e
così grazie anche al contributo
fondamentale di una pecora delle
highland scozzesi la biotecnologia ha
fatto ufficialmente irruzione nella
nostra quotidianità alimentando speranze
fantasie ma anche perplessità dubbi e
persino paura oltre due decenni dopo la
nascita di dolly la nostra capacità di
utilizzare sistemi biologici e organismi
viventi al fine di affrontare quelle che
sono le maggiori problematiche della
nostra era aumentata a un ritmo
esponenziale fornendo soluzioni sempre
più efficaci ed efficienti per
rispondere alle nostre esigenze
mi riferisco ad esempio a soluzioni per
spalmare il prossimo miliardo di persone
oppure per ovviare alla scarsità di
risorse naturali come l'acqua o ancora
per preservare l'ambiente
dall'inquinamento e non ultimo per
importanza per combattere e debellare le
malattie
alla luce di ciò non credo che sia
difficile immaginare per nessuno di noi
il termine e biotecnologia negli ultimi
anni si è diventato decisamente sexy
si si avete capito bene sexy le
biotecnologie oggi sono sexy e non solo
per l'entusiasmo che sono in grado di
generare con le loro soluzioni
innovative spesso rivoluzionare in grado
di farne un motore della grande
transizione della nostra epoca aiuto
bisogno e oggi soprattutto sono sexy
perché ci vedono indiscussi protagonisti
come ad esempio nel caso delle
biotecnologie applicate al mondo della
salute al tema della salute umana si
sono dedicati con grande passione i più
grandi innovatori di ogni tempo e di
ogni luogo e stando alle ultime
statistiche sulla qualità e la durata
della vita umana
i loro sforzi non sono stati vani anzi
pensate che dal 1800 ad oggi la
popolazione mondiale è passata da un
miliardo di individui a oltre 7 miliardi
e l'aspettativa di vita media è
aumentata di circa 30 anni dai 50 anni
del 1800 agli oltre 80 odierni e questi
dati sono ancor più incredibili se
consideriamo il breve tempo che è
intercorso per la maturazione di questo
successo
un tempo che è stato di circa duecento
anni e che è stato quello impiegato
dalla scienza medica per combattere in
modo effettivo le malattie individuare
nuove cure di fatto allungare la vita a
tutto ciò ha contribuito in modo
fondamentale il modello della medicina
sviluppatosi nel corso del ventesimo
secolo
un modello a cui tutti noi dobbiamo gran
parte del nostro benessere odierno qui i
protagonisti sono il medico e il farmaco
quest'ultimo concepito come una vera e
propria icona della salute il paradigma
è quello del one size fits o in cui la
cura viene concepita come un rimedio
valido per tutti
un rimedio progettato su basi
statistiche e sulla individuazione e
definizione di un paziente medio ora vi
chiedo
vestire ste mai un palombaro come un
pompiere
ovviamente no ma se entrambi avessero il
mal di testa
cosa fareste probabilmente offrire ste
ad entrambi il medesimo rimedio per le
micranie ora riflettete insieme a me
quante volte vi è capitato di assumere
un farmaco e non ottenere l'effetto
desiderato anzi alcun effetto
vi posso dire che capita più spesso di
quanto crediate
e non tanto perché il farmaco non sia
efficace quanto piuttosto perché
probabilmente quel determinato farmaco
non funziona nello specifico per voi e
questo può dipendere da una miriade di
fattori che possono essere legati
all'età al sesso all'etnia
dell'individuo oppure al suo stile di
vita alla sua alimentazione e al fumo
all'alcol o ancora al suo patrimonio
genetico quindi una miriade di
informazioni che concorrono a
determinare la nostra risposta ad uno
stimolo terapeutico
un vero ginepraio di informazioni a
volte è difficile da interpretare
difficile da comprendere e proprio per
esplorare e gestire al meglio questo
patrimonio di informazioni per navigare
con maggiore efficacia questo orizzonte
di variabilità individuale che è nata la
medicina di precisione
ove la cura non è più un rimedio valido
per tutti ma per ognuno
il protagonista è il paziente e la
medicina di precisione lo pone al centro
della sua indagine operativa
raccogliendone a riguardo informazioni
esperienziali quelle ambientali la
storia clinica quelle che possono essere
informazioni genetiche
il tutto al fine di disegnare lì intorno
un vero proprio a nuova ricetta della
salute
una ricetta che come tutte le belle
ricette a quattro ingredienti
fondamentali ed è personalizzata
predittiva preventiva e partecipativa le
decisioni qui vengono prese in stretta
collaborazione
non è tra il medico e il paziente che
stringono proprio una vera e propria
partnership di cura e lo stesso rimedio
terapeutico è completamente concepito e
realizzato a partire dal paziente o
nello specifico dai suoi geni dalle sue
cellule e dai suoi tessuti
è questo il mondo dei farmaci di terapia
avanzata che sono uno degli esempi più
innovativi di medicina di precisione ad
oggi disponibili alla cui nascita e alla
cui sviluppo il nostro paese l'italia è
stato uno dei più grandi contributori
tali farmaci sfruttano la stessa
biologia del paziente per intervenire
con tecniche di ingegneria genetica e
biologia molecolare al fine di
intervenire direttamente sul dna e
progettare geni che possano correggere
sostituire modificare o addirittura
regolare quelli difettosi
ad esempio per trattare alcune patologie
genetiche
oppure per armare e addestrare cellule
del sistema immunitario al fine di
combattere più efficacemente ad esempio
alcune tipologie di tumore tutto ciò è
semplicemente entusiasmante o
lasciatemelo dire decisamente sexy
eppure come per tutte le grandi
evoluzioni della scienza le terapie
avanzate sono agli inizi del loro
viaggio e come potete immaginare molte
sfide le attendono all'orizzonte a
testimonianza di ciò sono a presentarvi
nicole nicole è una paziente oncologica
affetta da una forma di tumore del
sangue che combatte con coraggio e con
determinazione da ben 9 anni circa tre
anni fa
nicola avendo provato senza successo
tutti i trattamenti disponibili sul
mercato ed essendosi rassegnata a quello
che poteva essere il decorso della sua
malattia è stata tra le prime pazienti
trattate con un innovativo farmaco di
terapie avanzate linfociti t di nicole
sono stati ingegnerizzati geneticamente
per combattere il suo tumore
in particolare le sue cellule t sono
state prelevate dal sangue sono state
modificate geneticamente per esprimere
sulla loro superficie un particolare il
recettore car in grado di potenziare la
risposta immunitaria e sono state quindi
rinfuse all'interno del suo organismo
ed ecco come con le terapie avanzate
abbiamo cambiato la sua vita
[Applauso]
[Musica]
agi rob
la storia di nicole è uno dei sempre più
numerosi esempi tangibili della grande
transizione in corso nel mondo della
medicina di oggi una transizione che ha
il paziente come protagonista e lo
coinvolge sia dal punto di vista
terapeutico
vi ricordo infatti che alla base della
terapia di nicole ci sono le sue stesse
cellule sia dal punto di vista
relazionale in quanto oggi il paziente è
sempre più bisognoso di maggiori
informazioni di maggiore educazione di
maggiore partecipazione in quanto
protagonista indiscusso della cura ma
soprattutto la storia di nicole ci
ricorda come queste innovazioni non
siano una panacea per tutti i mali
né tantomeno un rimedio valido per tutti
nonostante le ottime premesse infatti la
stessa nicole qualche settimana fa ha
ricevuto la notizia della ricomparsa
della sua malattia ea breve si
sottoporrà ad un nuovo trattamento a
base di terapie avanzate forza nicole
siamo tutti con te
non magia dunque ma scienza la scienza
di questo secolo che come sempre anche
nel passato avanza per tentativi
imparando e migliorando anche attraverso
gli insuccessi
abbiamo detto che siamo agli inizi di un
viaggio che non è privo di ostacoli
ci sono molte lezioni ancora da imparare
le nozioni da acquisire lo sguardo
dunque va doverosamente rivolto verso il
futuro e verso le opportunità e le sfide
che ci riserva
cosa ci riserverà al domani risponderò
all'italiana dipende e per aiutarvi a
comprendere meglio questa mia risposta
vi invito a fare in sé non è un veloce
tuffo nel passato avete mai visto questa
foto
in questa foto sono ritratti i
protagonisti di una delle più grandi
transizioni del secolo scorso
quella che ci traghetta letteralmente
nell'era della fisica moderna
nella foto alcuni giovani brillanti ed
entusiasti due dei quali vincitori del
premio nobel fermi e segre che dai
laboratori del registi tutto di fisica
di via panisperna a roma negli anni
venti e trenta del novecento in un
periodo di grande finzione e cambiamento
contribuirono a muovere gli straordinari
passi che portarono alla città della
fisica nucleare dell'energia atomica e
alle loro straordinarie applicazioni
anche nel campo della medicina e della
salute passi straordinari però non
sempre mossi nella corretta direzione
come ci ricordano le tragedie di
hiroshima e nagasaki
a seguito delle quali l'opinione
pubblica di allora iniziano a
interrogarsi sull'etica e su quelle
poteva essere i pericoli ei rischi che
si celavano dietro l'opportunità del
nucleare riflessioni queste non
dissimili da quelle che oltre
sessant'anni dopo animano il dibattito
oserei dire intorno all'applicazione
delle biotecnologie delle biotecnologie
della salute in particolare la moderna
bomba atomica risponde al nome di
eugenetica e ha dato un primo assaggio
della sua attualità qualche tempo fa con
il caso delle
le gemelline e cinesi venute al mondo
con il dna geneticamente modificato il
laboratorio al fine di lasciarle e
renderle più resistenti alle infezioni
da hiv
un caso che se confermato aprirebbe a
scenari quasi fantascientifici
superuomini e super donne con i risvolti
etici che potete facilmente immaginare
rischio opportunità dunque gemelline
cinesi o nicole il miglioramento della
salute umana attraverso l'applicazione
su larga scala delle biotecnologie e
oggi un tema tanto importante e centrale
quanto delicato e di difficile
valutazione e giudizio saranno necessari
tempismo e chiarezza per intavolare fin
da subito un dialogo aperto costruttivo
consapevole e informato al fine di
scongiurare il rischio della nascita di
un timore ingiustificato nei confronti
di queste grandi innovazioni
un timore che potrebbe vanificare i
risultati sin qui ottenuti con tanta
fatica e precluderci grandi opportunità
per il futuro
al tempo era la fisica oggi sono le
biotecnologie così come ai tempi dei
ragazzi di via panisperna una grande
sfida non solo scientifica ma
soprattutto etica e sociale
si profila distintamente all'orizzonte e
noi noi baio technicians siamo oggi
chiamati a rispondere ognuno è artefice
della propria sorte dicevano gli antichi
romani e anche questa volta la nostra di
sorte dipenderà dalle scelte più o meno
informata più o meno consapevoli più o
meno coscienti che come baio tech
generation saremo in grado di prendere
per il bene e la sopravvivenza della
nostra specie
nell'attesa che giunga la prossima
grande transizione
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]